all right guys what is going on welcome
to the next part in the Raspberry Pi
supercomputer series where we left off
we were installing the operating system
after your first installation you'll get
that rest by config page if you haven't
figured it out just hit finish there uh
then once you're done there and you're
at the line
you shouldn't have to login if you did
happen to do start X then you logged off
or something to log back in the default
username is PI and the password is
raspberry so log back in and type in I F
config and that will give you your I net
address so you're looking for it starts
with 192 168 okay so look for that
address once you have that if you're on
OS X or Linux operating system that
you're going to be like accessing via
SSH then you won't need putty but if
you're on Windows you will need putty so
head over to WWII on load putty here and
download putty I've already downloaded
putty so I don't need to do that again
once you've downloaded putty go ahead
and open it up and here's where you type
in all your that address that you just
got so mine was 192 168 0 20 hit enter
and this should come up and it should
ask you your login or my login of course
is PI and the password is raspberry as
everyone's is so now that you've logged
in what next thing I'm going to do is go
ahead and make this window a little bit
more easy to read for you guys so one
moment alright so that should be a
little bit easier for you guys to read
now before we go ahead and get started
the last thing I want to mention is the
way I learned how to make a super
computer out of my Raspberry Pi was
actually from the people at Southampton
University um they actually or
University of Southampton as the proper
name so actually if you go to google.com
and you just typed in a Raspberry Pi
supercomputer hit enter all these images
are actually from at you guessed at
University of Southampton where they
actually built this supercomputer so
this was theirs in their housing was
leggo and all that so actually they gave
a white paper um regarding how to
actually set up this Raspberry Pi and
all that so some of the information is
going to be coming from there since
that's exactly where I learned how to do
it
so shout out to the people at University
of Southampton for sharing all the
information as far as how they did it
and all of that and also shout out to
all the people they gave a shout out to
because actually in their paper it
seemed like there was quite the
collaboration between a lot of people
just to do it so anyways um yes don't
forget to say thanks to them so the
first thing it's always a good idea to
do with your raspberry pie and it's also
the first thing that they kind of
suggest that you do once you have your
pie all setup is indeed change your
password because every pie is PI at
raspberry and the username is PI and the
password is raspberry so that's what
we're going to change now so to change
your password what you need to type in
is passwd hit enter and it's going to
ask you your current password which is
going to be raspberry and then it's
going to ask you your new password so
type in whatever you want your new
password to be and hopefully it's
updated for you successfully so now the
next thing that you're going to want to
do is you could log out and log back in
around I feel like doing it so I'm not
gonna and now the next thing that we
want to do is go ahead and do a sudo
apt-get update so go ahead and type in
sudo which means Super User do apt-get
and update and now you're gonna update
this you're gonna see a bunch of stuff
spammed by blah blah blah alright once
that is complete the next thing that we
want to do is we want to get Fortran
we're going to go ahead and grab that
too so sudo apt-get install gee Fortran
and so we'll do that
and it continued there alright so next
thing that we're going to want to do is
we're going to put this in a directory
so we're gonna do make there I move my
mouse make dirt and we want to do home
PI and NPI ch3 if you follow their guide
they use NPI CH 2 and 3 is out now so
we're going to use 3 so hit enter and
we've made that directory now just in
case some of you guys aren't familiar at
all with bash and all that LS that tells
you like what's in the directory that
you're in if you hit PWD it tells you
what directory you're in and obviously M
Kader made the directory and now we're
going to CD into that directory that we
made so again if we LS we see that
there's our n pick 3 so now we're going
to just do CD mp3 or CH 3 and we're in
there if you want to know more about all
the commands and stuff I've actually
have a few tutorials on commands and
navigating bash for those interested
alright and now we're actually going to
go ahead and download this MPI CH 3 so
to do this you're going to do W get and
now you have to type in the web address
that you want to get it from now if you
have a way to copy and paste that is
fantastic but we're going to actually
just go ahead and type it out if I
remember I'll put the link in the
address and if I don't
the link in the interest the link in the
description and if I don't remember
someone remind me and I'll put it in the
description so the link that we actually
want to get from is kind of long so it's
going to run over here but anyway it's
going to be HTTP colon slash slash WWN p
i CH org slash static /downloads slash
3.0 point four slash NP i see h
um - three point zero point four dot
Tarr dot G Z so take a moment make sure
you got everything there right and then
go ahead and hit enter and it's going to
download this for us and we are all set
so now what that did let's go ahead and
hit LS again now we can actually see
that there is this tar ball year in our
file or in our folder rather or actually
the proper name is directory and now
what we want to do is unpack it so we're
gonna use tar xf z NP IC h - and just
the filename basically is three zero
four dot tar gz hit enter and now it's
going to go ahead and unpack that it
looks like it's not doing anything but
it's doing something alright once you're
done you'll look like this again let's
do LS and now you can see we've actually
got the folder so it's like you unzipped
a zip file for example so now what we're
going to want to do is make another
directory and this is where we're going
to put the build here so this is our
build directory okay so what we're going
to do now is m'kay dur or actually we
probably need to do sudo mkdir going to
do is home rpi
NPI and then again just hit the up key
to get the last thing you typed and then
we're actually going to do sudo make
directory home RP INPI
uh and then we'll do NPI three - install
hit enter good and now the other thing
that we want to do is the build
directory now so make our sudo make dur
and again home and this time it's in
home PI MPI CH underscore
old hit enter and now we're going to CD
into there so change directory so CD and
again home PI MPI CH underscore build
now we're in that directory and now
comes a bit of a long step but not the
longest step so what we're going to want
to type in here is uh my mouse pseudo
home PI MPI ch3 slash MPI CH - three
point zero point four and then slash
configure space - prefix equals slash
home slash RPI MPI /m pi3 - perps MPI CH
three - in stall hit enter and hopefully
we start seeing some output and now this
is going to take a little bit probably
five ish ten minutes maybe okay I'm all
done
uh uh if you're not you'll have to wait
and the next thing that we need to do
after we've built the files we need to
make the files so we want to do sudo
make hit enter and again you're gonna
have to watch stuff with bind if I
recall correctly this is the one that
takes the absolute longest to finish now
well this is installing I'm actually
going to go ahead and conclude this
video in the next video we'll start with
the rest of the things that we really
need to do as far as like installing and
waiting for things are concerned after
you know the downloading of the
operating system moving in and then
doing all this stuff we're pretty much
done with all of the waiting process
is so from here on out it's a lot more
of you know actual doing stuff although
we will make a copy of this this SD card
eventually but anyways so you guys do
have a little bit more interesting
things to look forward to rather than
just sitting here watching and waiting
for this to finish so hopefully I have
your hopes up so as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support
subscriptions and it is already done
nice and until the next video